[Music]
you're officially outnumbered yeah and
you look at this fabulous are you not
exhausted how are you being so pulled
together oh thank you I mean it really
is a game changer like not having to
breast feed and get back in shape I mean
that was I was so proud of myself that I
did that but I do feel like my house is
so full but in the best way it's
amazingly fall Kim Kardashian opening up
to et about welcoming her third child
via surrogate a daughter Chicago while
celebrating the launch of her new k'kaw
beauty collaboration with her longtime
makeup artist Mario at the Waldorf
Astoria in Beverly Hills now you told us
that North was a little bit jealous when
st. 2 arrived how are the kids doing
with Chicago they love her I'm so
shocked that North is so nice she's very
warm with her sister st. loves her I was
more worried about him that he would be
really jealous yeah I'm like how North
was was st. but he's so good with her
every day he has to give kisses and hugs
literally as I was walking and I was
looking on my phone I'm a video that
Kanye sent me with the kids like trying
to climb into her crib so are you
thinking about four already are we gonna
like live with three firm we gotta live
for a second I mean if it were up to my
husband we'd have like seven but you
know it's a lot I feel I feel like in my
soulmate
it might change I don't know maybe four
is all I can handle I don't know maybe
three is all I can handle
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]